[Música]
llega la economía ya France 24 para ello
Contamos con nuestro compañero Jorge
Hurtado aquí en el plató Jorge vamos a
empezar hablando de Colombia Porque ayer
ya las dos cámaras del congreso
aprobaron la reforma tributaria que
planteaba el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
Rodrigo aunque esto sufrió varias
modificaciones antes de ser aprobada
durante su campaña Petro propuso una
recaudación de unos 10.000 millones de
dólares para el Estado pero tras los
debates la reforma dará al Estado unos 4
mil millones de dólares adicionales eso
es alrededor del 1,2% del producto
interno bruto la reforma era necesaria
para cerrar el déficit fiscal que
actualmente ronda el 6% del pib pero los
críticos de esta reforma argumentan que
esta frenaría el crecimiento económico
el consumo y alejaría la inversión
extranjera le preguntamos antes al
economista Alberto Bernal León director
de estrategia global de XP in basement
sobre los efectos inmediatos de esta
reforma en un contexto decreciente
inflación y esto Dijo
esta reforma va a tener efectos sobre
los precios del consumidor en algunos
rubros en alimentos en confecciones
etcétera entonces va a generar una
presión inflacionaria adicional y que es
una mala noticia
pero bueno en fin está esta era como te
digo era era necesaria probar esta
reforma tributaria yo tengo muchos
cuestionamientos sobre algunos rubros de
la Reforma tributaria pienso que son un
pésimo presidente para la para la
confianza inversionista y el mensaje que
manda Colombia al mundo pero otros hay
que hay que ponderarlos no es importante
que que se incremente la digamos la
participación de las personas naturales
dentro del recaudo total en Colombia y
eso parte de eso se logra con esta
reforma tributaria en Colombia seguimos
teniendo un problema muy grande desde el
punto de vista de la estructura
tributaria que es que las empresas pagan
muchos impuestos y las personas
naturales pacan pagan pocos impuestos en
términos del del tamaño total de la
recaudación tributaria Y eso tiene que
cambiar Si Colombia en algún momento va
a llegar a ser un país desarrollado
Jorge para conocer un poco más de esta
reforma cuéntanos qué sectores son los
que más se van a ver afectados bueno el
principal los hidrocarburos en Colombia
la producción de petróleo y carbón
representa en la mitad de las
exportaciones de todo el país y es de
ahí de donde vendrá la principal fuente
de recaudación ahora el exceso de
utilidades del sector tendrá un nuevo
impuesto este sector ha tenido
cuantiosas gañán ganancias con los
precios internacionales del petróleo al
alza un efecto de la guerra en Ucrania
para las empresas petroleras sus rentas
serán grabadas entre un 35 y 60%
dependiendo del precio Internacional del
crudo y las regalías que pagan en las
regiones donde explotan recursos ya no
serán deducidas de sus impuestos Pero
esto es algo contradictorio porque la
reforma hace que el estado sea más
dependiente de las exportaciones de
recursos naturales para financiarse pero
a su vez la reforma también podría
alejar la inversión y exploración de
hidrocarburos la cámara colombiana de
petróleo y gas calificó de alarmante la
aprobación de esta reforma Pero qué es
lo bueno y lo malo de la Reforma así nos
responde nuestro invitado Yo diría que
lo bueno es que que más colombianos van
a tener que pagar impuestos Eso me
parece importante
quizás los colombianos más adinerados
van a tener que pagar un poco también un
poco más de impuestos y va a haber una
disminución en algunas de las exenciones
que existían para los salarios más altos
yo creo que todo eso desde el punto de
vista fiscal es algo que tenía que pasar
porque otra vez insisto Colombia está
saliendo una pandemia y necesita pagar
sus sus sus obligaciones
la parte lo que es terrible
definitivamente es el tratamiento que se
le da a las Industrias extractivas eso
va a salir demasiado mal va a generar
muy mal sentimiento desde el punto de
vista la inversión extranjera para
Colombia y eso porque gran parte de la
inversión extranjera de color que llega
a Colombia es para hidrocarburos o para
minería y eso va a generar una una
desbalancia adicional dentro de las
cuentas externas de Colombia entonces
muy desafortunado la política que
decidió el presidente Petro para con el
sector de hidrocarburos y la minería y
sobre todo un punto específico yo creo
que ese es un punto que de verdad va a
generar mucho daño desde el punto de
vista de la reputación de Colombia como
un país serio para la inversión
no han podido encontrar un solo país del
mundo ni siquiera en África en en en la
parte más más pérdida de África un país
que le cobre impuesto de renta a una
regalía eso es realmente desde el punto
de vista de de derecho tributario es un
exabrupto Jorge para acabar que otros
sectores también verán nuevos impuestos
por ejemplo Rodrigo la comida chatarra
algunos alimentos tradicionales de la
dieta colombiana fueron grabados algo
primero controversia porque no son la
principal fuente de recaudo y son
sensibles en un momento de elevada
inflación es importante si decir que
Colombia es uno de los países que menos
impuestos recauda en la región Ahora la
próxima semana se espera la conciliación
de este texto en el congreso y la
posterior firma al presidente Petro para
que la reforma ya se convierte en ley
bueno Jorge muchas gracias de nuevo por
este repaso económico a nuestros
espectadores sigan conectados en Francia